this is Star
[Music]
Talk welcome to Star Talk Allstars I'm
your Allstar host of this evening bill
nine I'm joined once again by my comedic
brilliant and sightful co-host the very
funny as well as funny looking Chuck
Nice yes thanks for being here again
today Chuck always a pleasure always now
today Chuck it may shock you to learn
that on Star Talk we're going to talk
about science what wait there's more
we're going to talk about science
literacy and the importance of seeking
knowledge and understanding of science r
large and all its manifestations I don't
understand what you're talking about I'm
talking about we're in a world where we
have alternative facts apparently that's
like a thing now and to help us out we
have Ross Anderson Ross is a senior
editor at the Atlantic where he oversees
the science technology ology and health
sections so uh Ross thank you for coming
and being part of Star Talk Allstar this
is great yeah it's a pleasure to be here
big fan of the show uh great uh wow
that's
great let me ask you this so for me as a
human here living a voter and taxpayer
and so on we have a real problem of
people not embracing science the way we
once did here in the United States uh do
you have any like why is that what's
happened yeah um well first I I'd want
to ask you uh to push back when you say
the way they once did what Baseline are
you kind of referring to there when I
was growing up when was Peak science
well when I was growing up in the
1960s there was this amazing optimism
about the future and there was this I
felt as a little of course I was a kid
felt this General belief that the
process of science would enable you to
put people on the moon to have freeways
connecting everyone in the United States
to have uh phone calls with video which
we got 50 years later and these things
would all be the and we'd feed everybody
and we'd cause the desert to bloom by
irrigating it on enormous scales with
things like the California Aqueduct and
Hoover Dam and Ross Dam and Grand
and we did we did all these things and
uh that optimism it seems to me it feels
to me as though it's not it's tied to a
denial of science where you now have
people who are against vaccinations you
have people who don't trust in
agriculture and genetically modified
foods and you have the big thing that's
going to affect everybody on Earth is
the denial of climate change now is my
perception incorrect am I misperceived
do we have uh statistics to back up my
claim yeah I think there's something
really I think uh there's a lot of
things going on there so I do think that
broadly people are still quite
optimistic about the role of Science and
Technology and innovation in their lives
and and the ability for all those fields
if they can be called fields to make the
world better um however as you point out
when it comes to vaccines or when it
comes to climate change people seem to
suddenly they're not taking a real kind
of objective look at the facts they seem
to be have made those positions more
about identity um they've been
politicized and what do you say identity
what do you mean I am a dorky white guy
from the East so therefore I feel this
way um it may be that so when I when
someone asks when a pollster asks me
let's say I I don't believe in climate
change when a person asks me about my
beliefs about climate change I'm not the
the in I don't want to speak for anyone
but it might be that I'm not going
immediately to some sort of objective
reading about the Earth's atmosphere and
instead I'm thinking
I'm going to authority figures within a
particular political movement that I
ascribe to so your expert in your if you
are a climate Denial in denier in this
example your expert is not a scientist
or or is not the scientific your expert
is your leader your political leader
well I want to go to something that you
said when you said the 1960s that there
was this optimism I wonder if there was
a point of Divergence where at that
point it was more or less true that
short-term business interests were
broadly compatible with science I mean I
think there's some exceptions when it
comes to kind of the early Clean Air Act
stuff for instance um and now we're at a
point at least with the fossil fuel IND
industry uh where there's a real tension
between instead of taking a real candid
look at climate science and uh you know
uh the stock price of Exxon Mobile for
instance so so people tie themselves to
that um to the leaders to the way of
life of of extracting fossil fuels
rather than to the
science unpack that as we say in the
business sure yeah I think that
political leaders make that calculus and
then there's all kinds of things that
happen where you know political media on
the right for instance uh becomes sort
of driven to uh seek out any scrap of
information that that could help uh you
sustain a climate denial position um and
to magnify that and to not say report
straight on the ipcc report or something
like that it's cherry-picking data is an
old problem but isn't that also due to
the fact that these political leaders
are um how can I put it without I I
don't want to be indelicate uh aren't
they in the pocket of uh of of Big Oil
let's be honest so when you have uh when
you have a convention where uh it's a
political convention and on the floor of
that political convention people are
chanting drill baby drill those people
don't have any uh inherent benefit from
from going drill baby drill it's the
political leaders that are being paid
off by if you're from Oklahoma City
Oklahoma your economy depends on
extraction depends on oil and gas yes
but your economy can also Depend and I
don't mind those people don't get me
wrong no he's some of his best friends
yeah listen yes but no I understand when
you uh don't believe something because
it hits you in the pocket that I'm cool
with that okay because guess what you
you're you're feeding your family and so
you say I don't want to hear it because
I got to put food on the table perfectly
understandable to me there are not
enough of those people to drive the
narrative that's what I'm saying so all
the other people that join with them
they do it because of a political
identity that is tied to the people who
have a financial tie to the issue so do
you agree with that uh Ross well so one
supporting point I think for uh for
Chuck's point is that big oil is to the
left of uh kind of the Republican
mainstream voter when it comes to
climate change you saw that in the Rex
Tillerson hearing right um when you tell
us what do you mean so loal executives
are are are mostly on board with climate
science to the extent that they they
kind of admit that human cause climate
change is a real thing um their
preferred policy objectives for dealing
with it might be different they tend to
kind of uniformly uh favor a carbon tax
uh as opposed to some of the other
things you know more radical uh
emissions cutting so what's a carbon tax
tell us about a carbon tax carbon tax is
that you you basically slap a tax on any
carbon emission so that you know you're
familiar with this idea of an
externality love the externality yes
love the externality
okay yes and this is in economics when
you pass the price of whatever you're
producing on to somebody else you
pollute the river and people Downstream
have to pay for it yes so carbon
emissions right now are a free
externality um if you run a coal plant
for the most part you could just steam
carbon into the air and and it's free uh
so a carbon tax would would tax that
activity um and oil executives are favor
this or Ross toson favors this Rex
favors you know it's they say that yeah
I mean we should take them at their word
right yes uh they they favor a carbon
tax how stiff a carbon tax um it might
be quite a light carbon tax that they
favor it might be that this is sort of
the best stalling tactic they've identif
yeah I I think that's more then Chuck
but then to Chuck's point which I think
you're about to address Ross was people
get on board with this even though
they're not invested in it that's right
get on board with this point of view
rather even though they're not invested
in it but the more interesting thing I
think is Chuck's point is that you have
people for whom their bottom line
actually is not affected by policy
positions on climate change at all and
it is only because they have either
grown up within or come to identify with
a political movement that takes climate
denial as sort of one of its signature
back edes um that's why they oppose
climate change so here we are let's say
we're on a science based show a science
show that claims to embrace science
literacy how would we change the minds
of these climate deniers and it's
important because uh the more carbon we
put in the air the more people are going
to be affected the more sea levels are
going to rise the more weather patterns
are going to change and it's all going
to happen faster than it's ever happened
and so on how do we change the minds of
people is it possible well I've got a a
three-point plan oh cool just kidding
just kidding just kidding I don't know I
don't know it's a hard problem well
here's what I here's my current thinking
here's my current thinking is the
so-called cognitive dissonance where you
have a world viiew that's incompatible
with what you're seeing so you have uh
this troubling situation in your brain
and you come up with a rational
rationalization and the more evidence
that count contradicts your worldview
the harder you rationalize it the double
down on your denial and the cognitive
dissonance the classics were when I was
in college was uh if you see if one
group sees the movie for free they the
movie is okay if another group pays
money for the same movie they tend to
like it more because they're more
invested in it and then there were
gradients like people who paid less for
the movie than more than the movie and
so uh when the more you're invested in
denying climate change the harder you
deny it to keep from having this Discord
this dissonance in your the front of
your brain s
singular
um there's a there's a region of the
brain that has conflict yeah the
conflict region I do Wonder um and this
is this is a strategy that that I think
has been tried to some extent uh
implicitly but you know there are
certain areas of science that do seem to
be bipartisan that you know people do
seem to take kind of a universal pride
and say uh the image is generated by the
Hubble Space Telescope Rockets um and
and quite a patriotic Pride right or
Rockets or right the Apollo missions
well but the Hubble Space Telescope
perfect yeah right yeah and so I wonder
if there's a way of integrating climate
science or all kinds of science you know
it's drilling down on the you know the
fact that the uh the empirical
scientific method is what gets you
something like a Hubble Space Telescope
you know that is this kind of Bedrock
edifice and that's also sort of telling
us this other thing over here about
climate change or vaccine science or
whatever it is um it's not a very good
three-point plan but it it's it might be
a direction well uh so we say all the
time space exploration because we're on
Star Talk space exploration brings out
the best in us and this is where you
find common ground you talk about
partisanship the example I give examples
I give everybody are Adam Schiff from
bleeding heart uh raving Blue State
California and John culber from Red
State double down the safest place is
the state capital building because
everybody's carrying a
weapon uh curon those two guys agree
like nobody's business on exploration of
Europa of all things a moon of Jupiter
you got to send a huge rocket out there
and invest for years to get the mission
pulled off that's where they find Common
Ground yeah now Culberson generally RIT
large is a climate change skeptic
extreme skeptic what I would call a
denier shiff is embraced very concerned
about it so where do we get these two
people together where they both have
these World Views that are just
incompatible yeah I wonder if it is in
you know the science of Venus or the
science of Mars um where you say look
the science that makes these very
missions possible you could not go to
Europa unless you had a sophisticated
understanding of how a planet works
right well there's more to it than that
or less to it than that people no and
the other guys Lamar smth from Texas
these guys have he's got a picture from
Hubble on his well a huge very sharp
highresolution color picture taken by
the H Hubble Telescope of a Starfield
deep space and yet he's a climate denier
this is surprising to us so there's
something some would you mention the
word identity there's something visceral
with these guys that
um they're not to us on my side of it or
maybe Chuck Dr nice's side of it uh
they're not embracing the same science
that that we are well since there's a
new sort of nationalist streak in
conservative politics one wonders if um
if the United States were to pay a
severe cost in status that was legible
to someone like Lamar Smith or even just
a a a everyday conservative voter um
would that be an important signal
because of our pulling out of Paris for
instance let's say we out of Paris and
we're sort of the laughing stock of the
world and um China emerges as this sort
of you know Ultra responsible new leader
of the world order um you wonder if
people would sort of double down in
backlash it's probably what would be
more likely to happen but there's
there's one scenario where people would
kind of register that and think about
wow it's a weird thing for the us not to
be at kind of the idealist bleeding edge
on a scientific issue I got news for you
we are already the laughing stock of the
world so it's a little late for that I
mean I do have but you guys just
anecdotally I have friends in Denmark
Australia and Britain that are just like
what and Japan and what are you guys
doing they're asking what what's up with
this and um but all those countries with
the possible exception of Japan have
their own kind of quite
strident uh
nationalist right-wing movements On The
Rise so uh what we want to do is bring
people together I believe we want to
bring people together and address
climate change in a big picture way so
if you think it's their identity they
want to be part of a movement is there a
way to influence that movement and you
had a cool idea there Ross where we're
going to we're make it a national thing
a nationalist thing that we're falling
behind the rest of the world if we don't
do blank take it what do we do Mr
Anderson well here's an idea we uh I'm
really interested to see what NASA's
promotional campaign for the James we
Space Telescope looks like as we come
closer to launch um and I do Wonder uh
perhaps it perhaps not
um you know it's it's it's tough to see
something like this happening in the
next few years but I do wonder if there
is a way to integrate planetary science
or uh just you know uh the larger NASA
Mission which obviously as as both of
you know uh has earth science as a very
high priority at least for the moment um
into the publicity in the runup to that
March I have a feeling that the James
Webb Space Telescope is something that
people are going to be very proud of
just like they were proud of curiosity
and just like they were proud of the
Hubble Space Telescope and New Horizons
New Horizons New Horizons right that's
right I think what we should do is uh
find a way to blame uh Mexicans because
that really seems to resonate with
people I think you're being ironic Chuck
no I I think if you just say don't let
Mexico they're stealing all of our
weather don't let Mexico steal our
weather Le in climate the astronautical
Congress was in guadara this year which
is being the Mexican people are very
proud it's the Silicon Valley of it's
already happening it's already happening
well maybe maybe they'll have like Bay
Area style weather in Canada before not
too long and we can kind of make America
cool again boy but this is a big problem
that I really want to figure out how do
we get people to work together on this
and I guess it's just everybody doubles
down is not is two is not is two but
yeah it has something not to do with
science it is U it's some other human
nature thing and so where do we what do
we do next Chuck I know you're cynical
bitter miserable guy I'm a cynical
bitter miserable guy mostly because I'm
a comic and that's you know really what
we are and that's why you love the
person that's exactly he's just it's
Limitless material and let me tell you
listen he's the J writer and Chief and I
for one do appreciate that well thanks
for your appreciation Chuck this is Star
Talk Allstar Edition and we'll be back
right after this with Ross Anderson from
the
Atlantic welcome back to Star Talk All
Stars we've been talking about
scientific literacy and Science
Education and climate
denialism with uh with Ross Anderson
from the Atlantic and I've been your
host Bill I here guest hosting on my
favorite
podcast the ones with Chuck Nice my
co-host here in the studio hey and uh
Ross Anderson is our guest and he is a
senior editor at the Atlantic but before
we get to uh before we get to the next
thing which which will be Cosmic queries
yes you have a new show playing with
science CH with science it's uh it's a
Star Talk branded show where um branded
that's hip that's that's what we
say the 20 pluses that's right so uh
it's a it's a show where we take iconic
Sports plays and weic sports plays yeah
so think of like uh the Immaculate
Reception right and this is 30 years ago
got lot of football yeah a little
football thing and uh we'll break down
it's been a lot of football since that
and you know what we're going to get to
all of that too the fog bow the fog
where it was foggy one day the fog Bowl
yeah fog Bowl so he you know what that's
a good idea for shows matter what about
the kinetic energy of a modern player
there you go how about that so all of
these things you're really good at this
this is all the things that we talk
about the thing show uh the thing that
amazes me about modern football players
professional players is how fast they
are okay so that's a show that I was a
kid they were fast and tough and took a
lot of punishment but they go so they
run so much faster and the money's in it
and so we actually we actually explore
that in a show where we talk about the
science of Sports Nutrition and strength
and conditioning as well as player
tracking through um um artificial
intelligence that they use so um we have
like uh uh we're going to be talking to
ocum manora Santonio homes we spoke to
uh Glenn Tobias of the New York Jets and
the uh uh Boston Red Sox who is a
nutritionist a sports nutritionist um
and uh it's a fabulous show it really is
so with that said as a matter of fact
and we'd love to have you
on behind it this has been a lovely
digression Ross Anderson from the Atlant
senior
the Atlantic is here and Cosmic queries
it isoss just registered that Chuck did
not invite me onto the show also well
you show us your sports chops all right
yeah I'm GNA work in for the rest of the
show why are we why do we have inter
city rivalries what human nature thing
is that I I mean it seems like a pretty
obvious tribalism thing right I feel
like in in my life I've most understood
tribalism when you know watching like a
Laker game winner or something like that
it's it's the safest gang war you can
ever have everybody lines up on they
time behind their team you got your
colors and everything like that and then
they can do battle and you can be a part
of it vicariously it's wonderful imagine
that if I were down on that
field I could hit that pitch I could
catch that sure I could outrun that guy
that major league athlete yeah sure I
could I could kick that field goal it's
amazing and make that putt that's hard
that's right and listen that's the great
thing about it it's like you can be a
fat guy on the couch and and when your
team wins a championship you can go we
won yes yes let's query so Ross you're
going to be on telling us about
tribalism yes I'm excited yes but first
a cosmic query take a Chu Cosmic queries
let's get into it and we always start
with a patreon patron and so let's go
with they pay to be on and absolutely so
how works here we can be bought we can
be bought much like you're politicians
people okay you are just a miserable man
today lead on lead on what's wrong with
me okay here we go uh off ven viersen
says how should I engage people in civil
discussion about science if they are
quick to to dismiss most science based
on their own biases or religious
background so you know we were talking
about that earlier uh but he's
broadening it out from climate denial to
just general science and there's a lot
of general science that is uh rejected
by people for various reasons Ross
why yes Ross why do people think that
the Earth is 6,000 years old yeah I
think it's tough when um when you do see
that signal in any kind of conversation
where someone is really committed to
having a very literal reading of the
cosmology of a a Bronze Age text that's
a tough situation to be in one that I
found um some success with recently is
going right at the flood story um by
looking at hey you actually don't see
genetic bottlenecks um when you look at
the lineage of every single animal on
Earth to two
individuals the people the deniers I
would spent a lot of time with those
guys you know in Kentucky they claim
that they they show calculations where
all dogs became wolves became just all
one that there's plenty of time 6,000
years is plent of time in their view the
the other one though that I think is
really good for the the flood story is
just uh pointing to the quite natural uh
scientific explanation for why there are
flood myths dispersed you know across
cultures all across the Earth and that's
because we had the end of an Ice Age um
and so the Seas rose right and you had
all these kind of coastal cities and
civilizations that were swamped and that
has a real nice hook into climate change
doesn't
it boy that's really going to win hearts
and there was a climate change 10,000
years ago and that's why everybody
actually it's very cool to me I mean
cool in a u in a intellectual way also
kind of troubling as sea levels rise on
our coastal cities today but uh we got
to find Common Ground all right let's
move on to Tim Shaw who says this I'm
worried that our progress will be
dangerously slow in a world where
alternate facts are something real and
not simply a joke um hey way to go Tim
uh how do you go about changing
someone's mind who is at a level of
debating clear facts is it worth it to
try or better to just focus on
advancements of science while ignoring
them so you Ross how do you deal when
alternate facts be become an actual
consideration how do you talk to someone
yeah I mean seriously is this like Uncle
Bob at Thanksgiving that we're talking
about or or this is like a prospective
voter what do we think well you know I
think both I mean Uncle Bob is one thing
but then when you talk about a
perspective voter you talk about how do
you get true information to somebody who
is who can consume it and know the
difference so you know uh that's that's
a really that's a problem well here's
what happened you guys enough people
embraced a worldview that we have an
Administration that has alternative
facts
now right so we're not reaching so we
they it is not reaching
somebody and do you know how we reach
them come on man you're a big time
journalist am I the problem no one's
ever called me that I'm going to say the
problem Ross though is that you are a
journalist and you are probably the most
dishonest person in the world that's
right and according to Steve Von I
should shut my mouth right away so I
can't answer this question actually um
no I I do think that it you know in the
years to come um I'm obviously in the
line of work I'm and I really want to
stay open-minded and and really try to
persuade people uh of of these
extraordinary achievements uh that that
science has produced um but at a certain
point look we've all been wrapped in
those conversations whether it's with
family members or people you meet
elsewhere where you're just not there
there's not common body of evidence even
uh that you know that any source that
you bring up people are willing to
discredit um or or question your motives
or whatever it is and in that case it
might be that we sort of have to sadly
uh kind of hunker down and um lean into
the culture of science where it exists
and fortunately for us uh not the
culture scientific achievement the
levers of government cannot limit that
uh completely you know there's ton
there's a ton going on in the private
sector obviously Elon Musk is is uh is
doing lots of exciting things and as as
you see advancements in those fields we
can all continue to celebrate those and
hope that people come around cool well
what if people don't come
around I'm not joking you guys I know
you're not joking but we have it's
suppose we end up with tariffs on our
most popular trading partner and we
don't have spare parts for cars or air
conditioners then I said it I'm going
black market avocado man it's going to
be awesome now everybody knows about
your brand that's right sorry and if you
put the nice brand the nice brand it'll
slip right in nobody even know nobody
know so uh uh anyway there's potential
problems and we have to find ways to the
word I want to use as reason with our
fellow voters but it's really it's
really a challenge let's take another
question all right here we go this is
Amy Zinda from Facebook who says this um
and you know before I read this and I I
know I'm I'm I'm kind of joking I'm
being a little Surly I'm not being
political I really believe that anybody
has the right to hold whatever political
beliefs you have so please do not write
me and say Chuck you're anti-trump I'm
not anti anything oh no I not I am not
I'm I'm just proa facts and Pro um
critical thinking that's all I am that's
all Chuck is that's it I'm not anti
anything okay me too I'm going to
co-sign that disclaimer and steal it
from myself there you go so anyway Amy
Zenda says this since there seems to be
a growing distrust of scientific
research funded by the government and
several frightening steps what is you go
ahead goe and several frightening steps
uh by the new Administration to quash
the publishing of results and
information what are some other sources
either online or in print for quality
scientific literature that we can rely
on in the coming
years it's a good question there Amy the
Atlantic obiously the
Atlantic Atlantic is your main source
Los
Anderson a magazine about what about
oceans Atlantic oce the Atlantic oce we
cover it's big no I think uh maybe
nature uh is is one that we can point
people to um the planetary societ
planetary.org yes for all your space
news yes um this is a great question is
is this question of authority if people
that discount authorities or experts in
fields then you you're
really lost or you can be lost so what I
said everybody the thing about the
modern world with the internet and so on
is you have to learn to filter
information yeah you go so go online
look at all the stuff and look for see
if you think it's reasonable
wow so you know that's funny because our
next uh question I don't know if this is
a question or not I think it might just
but be a rabid statement it might just
be a rabid statement from Peter Allen
Jacobs on Facebook okay I'm just going
to be honest I'm the one who wrote all
these questions
no no uh Peter Allen Jacobs says this
he's uh coming to us from Queensland
Australia he says the most in essential
invention is an internet filter which we
can reliably dis uish fact from opinion
from
BS No Such Thing Man and so that's what
I want to know so I'm asking both of you
with the Advent of fake news playing
such an important role in this past
election you're not political no I'm not
political I'm I'm really not I'm I'm
really asking I'm really asking how it
how would you Ross in your industry how
do you go about distinguishing fake news
is there a responsibility to to say like
this is this is not real like you have
the onion right but we all know if you
read it in the onion it's satire it's
not real so how can we have something
like that for actual news Ross yeah um
Facebook has been uh uh experimenting
with an algorithm where if enough people
say that something is fake or reported
as fake news it a little icon pops up
next to it that says this is disputed um
they they actually uh we we wrote a
piece uh arguing that they should buy
Snopes and actually have their own kind
of full-time factchecking team inside
just to kind of get the like the very
worst of the stuff off Facebook they've
also banned I think something like 180
Outlets already um from posting but uh
yeah they they've had some success with
this algorithm and and the word is and
this is all very preliminary research
but that it does actually work that that
when people see that disputed icon uh
fortunately so maybe Facebook will be
the ultimate honest broker in the end uh
they do there's not not a good chance of
that um you scared the hell out of me
just that well the thing about but the
but crowd
um crowd uh sourcing crowd review has
some value when if you have enough
people going on but you at the Atlantic
you try to be a mainstream journalist
right you are a mainstream journalist
and you have standards of research and
so on that's right so how many people
when you write a story of 2,000 words or
so on how much research do are you guys
do do
traditionally yeah like for instance um
I've been working on a sort of 9000w
climate change feature for our April
issue for the last you know 68 months um
that took me to Siberia um and it's been
copious amounts of research talking to
climate researchers and people in Russia
and uh uh everything in between I can't
really get into the details but youd
have to what what what did you see in
Siberia I I can't say but we uh we also
have just a devoted factchecking team
who uh for whom I am eternally grateful
uh it's amazing to publish a piece that
has rigorous factchecking behind it the
way we have in the magazine is just a
wonderful feeling it gives you really
solid ground to stand on uh how much
energy do you guys put into
uh deny in the fake news people do you
get do you get um I guess you have
letters to the editor that you filter
and so on sure but do you guys plan to
to what is the discredit fake news
outlets kind of thing yeah some I think
for us to take a swing at it and I don't
want to speak as though the Atlantic has
some exalted position in the world of
media but for us to kind of deem it
worth our time it has to achieve a
certain level of popular currency for us
to take I mean if we were we just don't
have the staff to be for instance
sifting Facebook all day kind of looking
for specious claims about science and it
would it would take up all of our time
because there are a lot and speaking of
take up all our time Chuck Ross will be
uh here this is Star Talk All Stars I'm
Bill NY with Chuck Nice and Ross
Anderson from the Atlantic and we'll be
back right after
this welcome back welcome back to Star
Talk Allstar Edition I'm your host this
week Bill Nye along with the brilliant
and insightful Chuck Nice and this week
nicely said this week Our Guest is Ross
Anderson who's a senior editor at the
Atlantic we're talking about science
literacy and I got to tell you guys I
feel like we go over the same ground
over and over that we are we are
scientifically literate we are well
researched and those other people the
those other people are not but I just
don't know how we're going to reach them
because it's important to reach them
we're all in this together and this is
the cosmic query portion of the show yes
so let's take a question look at it from
a scientifically
literate embracing the other side point
of view take it shuck okay I'm going to
give you I'm going to give you a good
challenge on that one uh Drew Huber from
Facebook says this are there still
scientists that are using alternative
facts to claim that climate change is
not real well there's the very picking
of data Ross you you deal with this all
day I take
it yeah I absolutely you do have people
who will for instance point to a
particularly heavy snowstorm in
California uh or a cold day in January
and say oh see yep no climate's not
changing just like we thought Senator
inhoff showed up in the on the senate
floor with a snowball found we laugh but
he and his the people that vote for him
at some level think he's on to the right
track on the right track wow yeah
stunning that is absolutely stunning but
there are fewer snowball days than there
used to be that's uh something to
consider but it's confronting people or
embracing people or becoming partners
with people who are have doubled down on
ignoring scientific what seem to be
provable scientific facts let's try
another query all right John Clemens
from Facebook is social media making us
dumb
uh is my star talk on your electric
phone handheld device St talks enriching
your life and making you that much
smarter right
everyone right
Uncle oh said Ross you deal with you're
used to be a print magazine exclusively
but how much of what fraction of your
business is online now uh I mean the
vast vast vast majority of it I mean we
we publish maybe 10 to 15 pieces in the
print magazine monthly and we publish
maybe 40 or 45 articles a day uh on the
web oh wow it's a factor of a hundred
thereabouts so uh do you feel that uh
there's
a people people who follow you online
don't accept your reporting as accurate
do you have the push back because it's
social media and it's dismissed as being
as making us Dumber
um sometime well I think there's a
couple things going first of all I want
to say that of of course like any human
being uh we beings we make mistakes um
and uh we regret them and we try to be
really transparent about correcting them
uh and as quickly as possible um but yes
uh as far as social media making people
Dumber I'm I'm just not I feel like any
totalizing narratives around social
media and it making us smarter or Dumber
are usually sort of themselves dumb uh
it's obviously a Nuance phenomenon I
don't know about you guys but I've been
I mean I found social media making me
smarter in all kinds of ways I feel more
kind of in touch with what's happening
uh in the world on a momentto moment
basis now whether what that's doing for
me psychology is psychologically is
another matter but I remember uh Gil
Scott Heron with the revolution will not
be televised turns out it is being if
you have a revolution it better be on
Twitter it's not happening absolutely so
um to that end imagine how much more
difficult it would have been no matter
how you feel about these ladies who how
much more difficult it would have been
to organize the women's March without
social media that's right with social
media it was U millions of people showed
up in several cities dozens of cities
and uh how do you Ross do you have any
opinion about this proposed science
March yeah well so uh one of the
responsibilities of my job is not to
advocate for uh political activism of
any sort but you're reporting we'll be
watching it with interest yeah okay all
right let's take another query chuck all
right uh this is oi Ocha uh oi is how
you spell the first name I don't know
how to say that o oi okay oocha oocha
there you go if people can't use facts
and reasoning to make well-informed
votes and there's little hope of
improving that
situation it's a theme today I'm telling
you this is on everything suck Star Talk
radio I'm telling you and I'm just I'm
going through pages of stacks of them is
there a payoff phrase there at the end
well the payoff is
um should we consider changing the way
we vote well this is hey uh Ross
Anderson you know the no matter what
else happened this is the second time in
my lifetime I guess it's the fifth time
in my lifetime that uh the popular vote
did not determine the who became
president uh is do you think there is
any way ever that the Electoral College
would be modified in any way um I it
sounded like that questioner was
referring more to uh should we be
selecting out people who are stupid
demonstrate some capacity for uh
evaluating judgments uh scientific
evidence to vote and I would say
absolutely not absolutely not ugly
history IDE like that um but uh
Electoral College reform uh i' probably
want to bring on one of my colleagues
from uh the political sectioning heing
interesting it's interesting idea well
everything's interesting do you think
it's
possible no not in the near term and uh
would it be any better or would it just
be the Electoral College as I understand
was created to prevent New York and
Pennsylvania from having too much
influence right 100 Trump has a good
point too when he says look I didn't
campaign on that uh it's it the the
campaigns would have looked totally
different it's not the case that oh if
we had run for a popular vote Hillary
would have easily won by three million
he would have lived in Texas for
instance yeah but he also said that the
Electoral College is a disaster
so I also thought it was genius and then
and then and then it's the best
invention ever uh once he won so and
also Mr Anderson do you have any are you
allowed to express an opinion about
interference in the election and by that
I mean well of course the direct of
course the direct interference possible
by
Russia the influence of the
FBI with these spous emails or redundant
emails at the last minute and then more
importantly this suppression of voting
where you try to create laws and
gerrymandering that makes it makes
certain people's vot votes um
ineffective or not influential the way
they would be otherwise yeah I think uh
since we're on this is a science show uh
I would I would say that it seemed to me
that you moved uh in order of strength
of evidence uh when you listed those so
I think there's excellent evidence that
people's that there's been suppression
of voting rights uh in particular places
for obviously politically motivated
reasons um uh and I certainly have no
reason to doubt the assertions of the
entirety of the intelligence community
that you know uh Russia seems to have
interfered um with this election but uh
you know I think we have to assign a
proper Credence to that given that you
know that evidence actually has not been
published and hasn't been vetted by
journalists it's we are sort of taking
intelligence uh officials at their word
see there Chuck you can't get that point
of view without a guy from the journal
from the mainstream media it's fabulous
I think it's great now um uh let's get
one more query and then pretty soon it's
going to be time for the lightning round
and uh so let's make it a really quick
one I don't think it needs a uh this is
Bob Ferell from Facebook when did Star
Talk turn all political what a
bummer when did it to this is your show
I'm trying I'm a guest host we're trying
to but here's the here's the scientific
question about politics okay uh how did
we get here it's a surprising thing
where we have
what would nominally be called an
anti-science movement that is very
popular and why is that what is what has
happened with the mainstream science
community that uh things have changed or
seem to have changed Ross oh
man I think it's interesting that no one
identifies as
anti-science hi my Manti science this is
my here's my business card you're right
yeah so it's it's it's not an I mean
people for instance uh much opposition
to vaccines is a matter of alternate of
people saying that you know scientists
uh are in fact the ones who are ignoring
evidence um so maybe that's something
that we can um it's it's a comfort to me
I'll be at a small one in in this uh in
these weeks uh that um people are still
appealing to science as an
authority are you How do you mean like
in the case of vaccinations they're
appealing
to I mean that it would be all the like
it would be really distressing if people
were just outright saying that actually
science is worthless it tells us nothing
um of interest on these subjects instead
of actually the scientist that I listen
to
or particular data are appealing to the
same intellectual standard see there you
goh yeah that my authorities are better
authorities than your your authorities
and uh this idea that the authorities on
the other side are part of a conspiracy
is remarkable H and uh and so we'll see
how that shakes out let's get another
query are we in the last five minutes I
think we are lightning time it's
lightning time okay here we go uh this
is Robert Lane if everything is made of
energy then everything that was or will
be is already here if humans are made of
energy where is all the energy coming
from to increase the population oh like
dude that's like so out
there but the reason humans are able to
live on the earth is we have energy from
a nearby star the sun and we grow food
yes there's uh internal energy in the
Earth that moves tectonic plates around
which has a great effect on the carbon
cycle and so on but the primordial
energy that created the sun came from
The Big Bang and you know why we had a
big bang nobody knows why there you go
so some people are very troubled by that
and they that would there's this huge
unknown other people think wow that's
cool let's go let's find more let's
learn more about that let's do astronomy
and Agronomy and Agriculture and physics
and chemistry and change the world
digress take it one more question there
we go
um uh this is Jess Woods from Facebook
uh dear Bill how can we effectively
teach the youth and educate others about
topics such as climate change Evolution
when we uh are encountering resistance
at the same time so well Chuck it's easy
you watch Bill Nye the Science Guy while
you're in school you you watch Bill NY
Saves the World on Netflix you listen to
Ross Anderson at the Atlantic and you
listen to Star Talk and turn it up
loud bingo I like it minute and a half
Chuck let's go here we go um let me see
oh God what are the odds of Neil and
Bill
reaching out to the administration uh to
propose realistic goals for man space
exploration so this is what we want to
do at the planetary Society we want to
have humans orbiting Mars in 2033
without increasing the NASA budget at
all with the people that are coming in
to NASA with the Trump Administration is
very reasonable we can move that to
orbits earlier and by orbits I mean
orbital opportunities 2028 here's what
we want out there everybody let's not
have a re set on on human space flight
let's use the existing Hardware the
Orion Space Capsule CTS 100 the um uh
spacex's Dragon capsule let's use the
existing stuff and advanced space
science and exploration in the meantime
everybody out there let us continue the
search for life with robots on Mars and
Europa a discovery of Life on another
world would change this
one planetary.org we'll tell you all
about there you go uh one last question
Chuck this is Hugo from Facebook says
can you demonstrate that the term
alternative fact is just a marketing
type rebranding of the term propaganda
take it Ross 12 seconds
propaganda
um where to begin he laughs out loud
you've been listening to Star Talk
Allstar we have uh this week's guest has
been Ross Anderson from the Atlantic
he's a senior editor Chuck Nice funny as
well as funny look and I've been your
guest host Bill Nye listen to Star Talk
Turn It Up loud thank you all very
much this is Star
[Music]
Talk